Narrator: Would you eat this avocado?
How about this one?
They're actually the same,
just one's been sitting
out for a few hours.
And sure, one doesn't look as good,
but that doesn't mean you
should just throw it out.
In 1989, the average
American ate about one pound
of avocados a year.
By 2017, that amount
had increased sevenfold.
But as much as we like to eat them,
the struggle with
browning avocados is real.
Some people might try to prevent it
by putting the avocado pit in the bowl,
but it does not work that way.
Just like with apples,
bananas, and potatoes,
the flesh of an avocado
browns when it's exposed
to oxygen in the air.
It's a process called oxidation,
and it happens when the
oxygen reacts with compounds
called polyphenols with the help
of enzymes called polyphenol oxidase.
This damages the tissue of the flesh,
in the process turning it brown.
But the brown color is not
a sign that it's spoiling.
You'd have to leave it out for a few days
before it spoiled from oxidation.
That brown color is actually
from a nontoxic chemical called melanin.
It shows up in everything from fruit
to the iris in your eyes.
Needless to say, that
bowl of brown avocado
won't hurt you.
However, the more
oxidation that takes place,
the more tissues it damages.
For example, bruising
or chilling an avocado
for too long can lead to
significant oxidation,
which actually damages so much tissue
that it changes the texture
and flavor of the fruit
so that it's mushy and bitter.
But a little browning
won't make a difference.
To prove it, we did an experiment.
We served green avocados and avocados
that were left to brown for a few hours.
Gina Echevarria: "Okay,
tastes like a normal avocado,
I think."
Abby Tang: "I don't like that one.
I don't know why.
I just like, it tastes a little bad."
Clancy Morgan: "Pretty
strong taste, I would say.
Pretty strong avocado, earthy taste.
But yeah, it tastes very ripe."
Echevarria: "Yeah,
pretty standard avocado."
Tang: "It tastes like a
regular avocado but rotten.
Why did you feed me a rotten avocado?"
Echevarria: "I feel like
that one actually tastes
a little bit better."
Morgan: "Oh.
Oof."
Tang: "This one doesn't taste
rotten, so that's good."
Morgan: "Okay, that is
much more ripe, super mushy."
Echevarria: "The other one
kind of just tasted like
wet paper,
and this one actually
tasted like something."
Tang: "This one's fine, I like it enough.
It's an avocado.
They taste the same other
than one tasted older."
Cameraperson: "And that's the first one?"
Tang: "The first one tasted older.
It was, like, sour.
And the second one tasted
like a regular avocado."
Narrator: How fast your avocado browns
depends on the environment,
like how much oxygen
is in the air, what the temperature is,
and how acidic it is.
Warmer temperatures accelerate
the chemical reaction,
turning your avocado brown faster.
But if you squirt some citrus on the top,
the acidity prevents oxidation,
and you can keep it
looking fresher for longer.
Either way, even though we couldn't agree
on which tasted better,
both were perfectly edible.
So next time you have some old avocado,
don't just throw it out.
And if the unsightly brown
ruins you're appetite,
just give it a quick stir, and voila.